or other top story new developments now
on the Oakland A's baseball team moving
right here to Las Vegas thank you for
joining us on this Monday at 4 I'm Brian
Loftus I'm Kirsten 's the A's building a
team off the field and it potentially
includes Bally's and a stadium on the
side of the Tropicana that's where we
find eight news now investigative
reporter Kyle Payne the details Kyle
and there are lots of big questions like
will the Tropicana Hotel behind me be
torn down but it seems the more we know
the more we don't know
what we know now is that this is an
opportunity for Las Vegas and the state
of Nevada honestly to expand their
Sports presence state senator Scott
Hammond letting us know what he knows
and today Bally's announced the A's
stadium will occupy nine of the 35-acre
Tropicana site it will hold 30 000 fans
to cheer on the A's over 81 regular
season home games and they project two
and a half million people to visit every
year what we also know is that they're
really concentrating on this site at
Tropicana and Hammond also told 8 news
now what he doesn't know and so we just
don't know how large of an ask like how
much money is it going to cost taxpayers
and what's the return on the investment
before the A's decided to switch
development sites and sides of Tropicana
Ave they were asking for half a billion
dollars in tax breaks now they say it
might only be 395 million all of that is
up to the legislature but what's the
timeline as far as the bill not sure
exactly when it's going to come the bill
might get introduced sometime this week
they're waiting for results of a traffic
study but nobody really knows what will
be in it or who will introduce it as
between the state senate and the
assembly potentially even the governor
last week the A's worked out a deal with
the powerful Nevada Culinary Union which
has more than 60 000 workers mostly in
and around Las Vegas that will give A's
workers the right to organize and
negotiate Union contracts in the
meantime Bally's is Fielding calls from
interested developers one real estate
developer who pledged 175 million to
help improve the Tropicana site so we
know that this is a great opportunity
the lawmakers are in session in Carson
County until June 5th state senator
Hammond says that's plenty of time to
get a bill through both the house and
the assembly they have been working out
the details for a couple months already
back to you Kirsten